boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
super excited to be talking about the
top 5 reasons why we are in a simulation
this is an epic conversational topic
that I love so much it's a great thought
experiment alright let's jump into it
alright first point the universe can be
broken down into code
this means algorithms this means scripts
this means from the basic mathematical
and constant principles of the way that
we can understand how things operate on
a universal code based level so as I
think about things I think about them in
this sense I think about them in this
crazy sort of description of our reality
in a mathematical codified way and it
really helps me understand how this is
in fact a simulation and so it's a very
exciting way to perceive things and I
can give you some more of these
interesting sort of algorithms and
scripts here's one for example the way
that atoms move the way that cells move
the way that their innards their inner
protons and neutrons and electrons the
way that the mitochondria and the RNA in
the DNA ribosomes how they all work
together inside of an actual cell or an
atom and this is one of the complexities
that can be broken down into algorithms
into scripts guess what else can we can
as well humans and civilization can be
described through algorithms and scripts
here you can see a red light means stop
a green light means go one of the
easiest algorithms to follow and
understand another algorithm that we see
here is for example you have all Motor
Vehicles and you have the way that the
engineering and the design behind a
motor vehicle and an internal combustion
engine or electric engine actually work
again more code more understandings of
how everything can be codified humans
follow this as well in so many other
ways why I want to
jump before we get there I want to jump
to another example which is through
habitable zones habitable zones are
another one of these ways of perceiving
orbital dynamics the ways that an Earth
orbits a star or Rock orbit stars
planets orbit stars well there's
different orbital periods well how long
as Earth's or its orbital period is
365.25 days that is a script that it
orbits the star that has an algorithm
that it orbits the star every 365.25
days the same thing is true about the
variable that we can calculate here that
the earth is 93 million miles from the
star that again is a specific
mathematical variable that is in the
code here and as you can see mercury is
too close to the star to harbor life and
so is Venus and then Mars is too far as
well as the other planets outside and we
can see in other places of the universe
there are tons of other examples of
rocks in the habitable zones of their
stars and here's the way that we can
understand ourselves as an algorithm as
well not just at the cellular level but
you can also understand it at the organ
level that the heart beats a hundred
thousand times a day that the heart
beats almost three billion times in a
lifetime nowadays about 30,000 days or
so to live what are these sort of
codified ways that we can understand why
we are in a simulation how we are in a
simulation why is understanding reality
at this level so so important and again
this is Adam's cell dynamics
civilizational protocols orbital
dynamics heart beats and I want to put
this into perspective as video games
because this is super relatable this at
times is like video game will guess what
so is when you think about playing as a
video game character in a video game
Mario for example Mario understands the
mario world mario understands that mario
must complete the end of the level mario
must go through the journey mario must
collect these coins along the way and
defeat these bad guys well don't we have
a similar thing here what what is our
coin our coin is money what is the way
that we complete objectives and get to
the end of the level well that is
basically our
milestones of our lives what we set as
our ambitious goals and dreams are
finishing up our levels and leveling up
what are we doing we're gaining
experience points what's another good
example pac-man what is pac-man pac-man
it understands it's pac-man world where
pac-man must go and collect these
individual items that feed it food that
level it up that gain its experience
points when it takes one of these one of
these objects that it knows it's now
understood the algorithms that it takes
one of these larger objects it makes it
a immune to the monsters attack and it
can go and consume the monsters for
extra points and for extra time to be
able to consume food again it's being
understanding of the variables of your
world of the code of your world another
great example Laura Croft and Tomb
Raider in the game you're completing
quests you're now in these realities
that are basically completely
indistinguishable from a reality we're
getting there this G's games are getting
very close to indistinguishable where it
actually looks like you are the
character in the game in this place in
the world achieving these quests again
knowing your environment knowing where
you are in the map knowing what your
inventory is isn't that the same thing
knowing what your bank count is your
inventory knowing what furniture you
have in your house is your inventory
knowing what messages you have in your
inbox is your inventory right these are
the ways of understanding our world in a
codified way that gives us a deeper
better understanding of the world that
we live in broken down into code alright
so let's go on to point to point two is
that we are each playing a character
role in the big story of a game we were
just giving you the examples of Mario of
pac-man we were giving you the examples
of Laura Croft and Tomb Raider well what
about us what about us and how we are
each playing a character role in this
big story called life alright so when we
think about it that way we actually gain
a very interesting insight because we
realize that there have been so many
other videogame characters that have
played in this story of reality here's
Martin Luther King playing his role in
propelling the civil rights movement
this is a one of so many videogame
characters that have made up
found impact on civilization there have
been a hundred billion humans that have
lived and died before us today each
taking their own character role in this
big story in this big game that we're
playing together each one of these
humans that you see even in this picture
there has their own unique role in the
story just like you and I have our own
unique roles in the story that we are
characters in this big game and all
these hundred billion characters have
had unique stories some of them have
been the first ones to pioneer creating
the airplanes that we now use every
single day creating the antibiotics that
we use every single day creating the
Internet and the cellular
infrastructures that we use every day
making it ubiquity in food and water and
electricity and education health care
all these things that we take for
granted that we don't express gratitude
for these people leveled up their
characters in the story and gained these
experience points in these specific
skill levels and attributes of
engineering or math or science or art or
history or language or whatever they
ended up pursuing education and building
and helping other people with so
building that value leveling up your
character is so important and you can
level up in a bunch of different
attributes here is what we do now what
we do now in our 2019 mentality in these
as we move in the next couple decades as
we're making these social profiles and
any social profiles we can do things
like have profile pictures have likes
have banner photos share we can share
with their friends share at their
audience we have message but we have
messages right how is this not like a
character that's running around in a
game that has its own little inventory
bag and has its own messages and can
edit their profile edit their appearance
what they're wearing in the game all
these different types of things this is
such a profile page to a video game
character and we have to remember that
as we go and figure out what exactly we
want to do with the limited amount of
time we have we only have 30,000 days to
live and we're to spend a third of those
sleeping we only have three billion
seconds to live a third of those
sleeping that we have to pick and be
vigilant with our time with what we want
to do what attributes do we want to
level up this is the most important
thing is to be visual
with our time vigilant with our
attention and pursue what brings us the
most self-actualization the most meaning
in our lives it is completely up to us
to be able to figure that out for our
individual selves meanwhile also taking
into account the betterment of the
collective simultaneously and we must
not forget as we do this that the that
another one of the ways to perceive
things that really accelerates the way
that we think about things is this big
history perspective when you think about
evolution you think about the reasons
why we may be in a simulation well you
have to wrap your mind outside of your
little twenty five year time period
fifty year time period however long
you've been alive ten years thirty years
etc you have to go out larger than your
lifetime you have to go back to what it
was like not only living fifty or a
hundred years ago but to the roots of
civilization to ten thousand years ago
when agriculture was started to over a
hundred thousand years ago when we were
discovering language and we're
discovering art and we were discovering
ways to communicate with each other past
just these grunts that when we
discovered the basic ways to survive and
communicate and collaborate on a on a on
a on a communal level that when you look
at that then that's still just a drop
that's only a hundred thousand-plus to a
million or so years ago then that's only
when humans evolved from from chimpanzee
prior to that were dinosaurs prior to
dinosaurs prior to the asteroid
collision prior to that was the
explosion of life the single cell to
multi cell organism evolution of life
that an even prior to those 4.5 billion
years was darkness was darkness and some
light darkness and some light some stars
of off some planets of awesome life
potentially evolves but we didn't have
life here on earth so you got to realize
this big history perspective that this
simulation is so old that the simulation
is 13.8 billion years old and it's so
old that it's so hard for our minds to
wrap around how old the simulation is
and we'll get to why this is also
extremely important in a little bit
remember take yourself out of this
little short this short life out into
this longer time period of this
simulation
all right in in in again when you
immerse yourself into these different
time periods like 10,000 years ago when
we're first making agriculture when were
first using fire when we're first
planting wheat rice grains etc when were
first domesticated animals and helping
us first making pottery first mean clay
first making these homes and and really
sitting down and these weapons these
these tools that we were using that it
gives you a deeper perspective into how
we got to where we are today and how
that can totally be seen again wrapping
your mind outside of the short-term
thinking we are one we not only evolved
from just the evolution on this planet
4.5 billion years ago but we don't there
there is no life that has been seeded
that we've discovered outside of Earth
so all these humans that have evolved
from all different places in the world
all different cultures all different
languages all different styles of living
are all from humans were all from
evolution we are all humanity and it's
time to play and behave like we are all
from humanity and we have to figure out
how to best do that together we have to
have the right discourse we have to put
together the right resource flows and
protocols frameworks trust based
frameworks eradicating malevolence and
violence and figuring out we are one
here on earth we all this is again this
is a crucial way of understanding how
we're in a simulation we all seeded all
life seeded from Earth so what Fermi
filters can potentially be in place that
are gonna stop the life from moving
forward okay if you want to retain the
seed of life you got to move through
these Fermi filters the dinosaurs got
hit by a Fermi filter they got hit by an
asteroid which stopped them from
progressing well guess what humans have
almost we had two instances in just the
Cold War where we almost had mutually
assured destruction and died and it's
because of Vasily arkhipov
and stanislav petrov in 1961 1983 and
that's the reason why we are here today
because those two stopped mutually
assured destruction from happening in
the cold war between russia and the
united states we have to be more
vigilant with the way that we can
mitigate existential risk and that
existential risk is not just nuclear now
now it's artificial general intelligence
it's continued to be asteroid issues now
it's biotech warfare
neuro technology warfare we have to be
very very vigilant to make sure that the
life can continue on earth otherwise our
character roles in this entire big story
of a hundred billion humans evolving
here will disappear and so it's very
important for us to realize how to get
past these Fermi filters and over come
them okay that was 0.2 we are each
playing a character role in this big
story of a game all right
point number three
point number three tweak the variables
in the code understand how to design
universes so what would actually happen
if you went and started tweaking the
math and tweaking the physics what would
that look like if you could tweak the
code of the universe so here you see the
Big Bang you see what happened after the
Big Bang and how it ended up evolving
all these galaxies and then how it
evolved all these solar systems and
where life has now evolved in just this
one Rock on the star that we know of and
how would it have changed if you could
change the math in the physics what if
the gravity on earth wasn't 9.8 meters
per second squared
what if it was different what if the
molecular composition of water wasn't
two parts hydrogen one part oxygen what
if what if the what if the proximity of
the earth to the star wasn't 93 million
miles what if it was only 50 million
miles and what if the star was a little
bit dimmer so that could still evolve
life how would it evolve if our earth
wasn't it wasn't 8,000 miles in diameter
but only 4,000 miles at a time what if
it was sixteen thousand miles in
diameter so again tweaking the math
tweaking the physics tweaking all these
different variables is so important and
going even further and saying well what
if we program math and physics to be
completely different before the Big Bang
so that's the universe design question
at a deeper level it's what happens when
you change the mathematical constants
the speed of light what if you altered
the speed of light what if you altered e
equals mc-squared what if you altered
force equals mass times acceleration
what if you altered
these equations that we govern these
mathematical constants that govern the
way that our universe has evolved in our
math and physics evolve so this is again
this is an interesting way to analyze
the way that the trajectories of
civilizations that flourish would be
different so what would it look like if
we weren't DNA and if we weren't
carbon-based beings what if we weren't
like this what if we were different if
we were coded differently not an ace T
season geez what if we were coated in
something else what if it wasn't a
double helix in nucleotides what if it
was something else what would that look
like if we weren't carbon-based we
didn't have these weird eyes where you
could see someone's soil we didn't have
those weird organs of a heart where we
put food inside of one end of our
gastrointestinal tract and then it went
and digested inside of us for energy
that the Sun grew on earth and then we
pooped it out the other end what if
things were designed in other ways these
creatures behaved and looked in other
ways different perception eyes touch
skin feel taste other things think about
that think about that because that is
what it means when you sit at a
whiteboard and you design a universe
that is universe design what would it
look like if you were completely at a
whiteboard and you could pick whatever
you want to design a universe then you
could command your own style of a game
your own universe design your own
simulation how would you simulate a
reality what would you do in the math
and physics what would you do with the
art how would you paint and illustrate
the simulation to potentially awaken
well how would you see these beings that
would then awaken and become conscious
of the fact that they are in some sort
of a universe that you've designed so
again think about this at a whiteboard
pre-big bang how would you design a
universe completely different than these
rocks orbiting these stars and these DNA
coded carbon life-forms think about that
that's a fascinating thought experiment
challenge yourself to think about
universe design civilization design and
the design of these of this life that
would emerge and how would it emerge
with these with these
with these whiteboards I love I love
letting the imagination run free letting
creativity run free like it wants to be
and that's why we must raise the
standard of living around the world so
people have their basic needs met so
their imaginations can be unleashed to
the fullest potentials their creativity
can flourish we need that all right so
again that is tweaking variables in the
code that is designing universes
remember that universe design all right
and then we move on to point number four
in the top five reasons we are noticing
relation point number four program the
math and fast forward 13.8 billion years
to see ourselves this is a really
interesting way of thinking about things
this is like can you can you actually
think about what it would be like to
program the exact math that we need in
order to run the simulation of what this
reality has evolved to be like so
literally you're pressing start the
start button on the Big Bang and you're
letting it play and instead of letting
it play over 13.8 billion years you just
literally fast-forward 13.8 billion
years in this exact same coded Big Bang
press fast-forward 13.8 billion years
and you land and guess what you see
exactly where civilization is at now on
this rock orbiting the star and you see
it exactly where it has where there's a
US and there's a China and there's a
Raja and there's a Middle East there's
an Africa or South America etc etc
there's there's a GDP and there's
creativity and there's the DNA coda
beans etc you could see all of that
happen you can even stop at the 66
million years ago mark and you could you
could watch the asteroid hit the
dinosaurs because again you are
literally observing the evolution of the
Big Bang for because you programmed it
to come to this point 13.8 billion years
later you programmed it a certain way
and then you press start and then it
went okay so now now the question is
what would be the computational
requirements
that are needed do you need quantum
computing do you need nuclear fusion
what do you need because I find this to
be very interesting quantum computing is
an interesting field that may be able to
help us greatly with projects like
extremely complicated simulations
nuclear fusion is another one of those
things that may be able to help us
that's what the star does all the time
to provide energy to the entire solar
system and what all the stars do to
shine all the light on us and their
rocks at night it's awesome you can see
it all at night and then what would in
what's exact what else is extremely
interesting about this is that it will
in Dees renting these simulations with
nuclear fusion with quantum computing
with whatever the necessary
computational architectures and
infrastructures are to be able to do
this excuse me
will be extremely valuable for us
because running simulations is super
freaking cool and it can teach us so
much and simulations are great for
running not only for running what it's
like to fast forward 13.8 billion years
and for us to learn from ten thousand
years ago it was like and for us to
observe people in agriculture settings
and stuff like that for the first times
for us discovering language and watching
us through the lens of other humans
discovering language so we can watch all
this and unfold but also because we can
run simulations of things like medical
simulations for our health how does how
does dropping in in a certain molecule
into someone's body how does it affect
their brain how does it affect their
body their their their organs how does
it affect their tissues their cells etc
how can we prolong life how can we how
can we eradicate aging how can we
digitize consciousness how can we evolve
so that we can live longer so that we
can creatively create more value into
the world as humans that we can watch
civilization flourish for longer periods
of time that that is very exciting stuff
what would you do if you could be around
that long so these simulations are an
ultimate mirror to us this is this is
what it's like when when things become
completely indistinguishable with the
virtual realities
when we will realize that holy crap we
can program realities and now I can jump
into this virtual reality when a
complete haptic suit completely
connected through my brain everything
and I can't tell the difference between
that virtual reality that I've entered
in this reality so I could be in that
virtual reality for 80 years and then
right at the end I come out and I'm like
whoa that was a virtual reality and
that's this life that at 80 when I
passed that I'm just gonna be like whoa
that was a fun game and then I just
strap in and I go into the next virtual
reality and I just keep playing and I
keep jumping between these worlds
between these realities between these
rocks orbiting stars or however else
these universes can be designed I'm
excited to design these universes to
design these virtual realities I'm
excited to teach people about what it
can be like for a civilization to
maximally flourish to be a pinnacle
civilization and that requires some of
these really interesting thought
experience it requires us to be more
heart centric to understand that unity
to understand the emotional intelligence
the connection that we have to one
another in the seed of evolution called
Earth so okay again 0.4 program the math
and fast-forward 13.8 billion years to
see ourselves this is a very exciting
thought experiment everything else we
can potentially learn from it along the
way
all right and the last one point number
five point number five is common
interest earned okay multi-dimensional
forces at play on earth all right so
what does this mean these
multi-dimensional forces that are at
play on earth well there's a lot that's
happening on earth that we don't really
understand we're here in these in these
meat puppets and these flesh vehicles
and wherever consciousness was seated
from we don't know if it's actually
localized in the nervous system
throughout our bodies we don't know if
we were in some whatever happens before
death before birth and after death so
again before birth after death your life
is here or what are those in-between
phases pre birth and after death whether
there be reincarnation what not whether
there be some sort of an in-between
phase where the soul or the spirit goes
and communes with other people with
other souls and spirits
and decides where they want to go play
next which rocks orbiting stars they
want to go play at her which universes
which parallel universes which
multiverse where they want to go and
play next because this is
multi-dimensional this is some next
level this is not just this perception
that's so limited
we can only see the visible light
spectrum here we can't see anything in
the infrared we can't see anything in
the ultraviolet we can't see anything
in all these other areas of the ultra
electromagnetic spectrum and we can't
even see gravity we can only feel this
gravity pulling down on us we can't see
all these interesting things that are
happening around us because our
perception is so limited so then when
you think about what goes on in the 4th
5th 6th 7th 8th hypothesizing all these
dimensions hypothesizing the
multidimensionality of reality what is
actually coming through us so you know
this is this is this is what I say to be
one of these really crucial
conversations is what are the games that
are being played on earth right now what
good or evil forces are at play what is
potentially at stake here where did
these characters come from why are they
choosing to play on earth has it ever
felt like to you when you encounter
someone else that is also playing for
this good team or this light team where
they're trying to help awaken people or
enlighten people to this ultimate
gorgeous beautiful destiny that we are
these beautiful gorgeous humans on this
planet that are so flawed but so perfect
at the same time and how we can
maximally flourish together how we can
find this love and compassion from
within and learn how to work together
and become a pinnacle civilization and
interstellar civilization that when you
find those people doesn't it feel such
an interesting coincidental essence that
that there is something deeper going on
where the souls or the spirits are
playing here potentially that there is
that whatever is at stake here on this
planet is actually really meaningful
that earth actually plays a really
important role in the cosmos that life
on this rock plays a really important
role in the grand scheme of things and
it's also weird when you look around you
and you see sometimes humans they're not
necessarily maximizing their potential
what is at stake
is that play what is going on what is
holding people back from their maximum
potential what is happening what forces
are coming into play on earth that want
to slap want that are seemingly sucking
the life force out of people through
these through these rigged political and
economic systems that don't necessarily
maximize the catalyzing of the most
optimal flourishing of a civilization
but rather exploit an extract from the
way that humans behave so that certain
ones can suffer and other ones can
flourish so what are those negative
forces what are those evil forces at
play how can we eradicate those
parasites how can we maximize the
flourishing of all how can we figure out
how to commune with the harmony of
nature and the harmony of the universe
and prosper so these are these
interesting multi-dimensional questions
about the forces that are at play and
how we can best figure out how to move
forward
are there non-playing characters on this
planet are some of the souls or spirits
fractally knout into different body
simultaneously why does it feel
sometimes when you go really deep into
meditation or really deep into
psychedelics are really deep into
communing with the infinite that you can
feel like you are you and everything at
the same time all other humans all other
beings on the planet all other lifetimes
that you've lived or experienced why
does it feel like you feel like you're
everything all at once all right so this
is the top five reasons why we are in a
simulation this has been very
interesting to explore with you all
let's go ahead and go through a
highlight one more time on all of these
all right one the universe can be broken
down into code it's so crucial to
understand this first principle math
constants equations formulas algorithms
scripts the way that cells are atoms
work the way civilizations work orbital
dynamics work even your heart be how
that works
thinking about things from the
perspective of a Mario or a pac-man or a
Laura Croft understanding their game and
knowing how to level up your character
in the game and that's the second point
that is we are each playing a character
role in the big story of
game and that we must know how to
maximize our own potential in the short
time that we have in this 30,000 days
time period we have to know what
attributes we want to level up and level
up those attributes we have to know that
we all evolved from one union with
nature here on earth and that we have to
overcome these Fermi filters these
existential risks that are in place and
next is this tweaking these variables in
these code and playing around with the
math and the physics and the trajectory
of civilizational evolutions to know how
to design new universes as well to play
around with what it would be like to
have a complete white board and be able
to play with art math and physics that
design whatever else pre Big Bang how
would that civilization how would those
evolve again not necessarily rocks and
stars and DNA coded beings but other
completely different things
think about that challenge yourself and
design those things and release them to
the world because it's really exciting
and it's an awareness expanding thought
experiment let the imagination run free
for programed the math and fast forward
13.8 billion years to see ourselves this
is so crucial if you can program a
simulation with the code of what we had
here in the Big Bang that we've
experienced in fast-forward 13.8 billion
years people can become awakened and to
realize that this is a simulation
because we just ran the same simulation
we are seeing ourselves think about what
computational requirements are needed
and think about the indistinguishable
virtual reality environments and how
after an 80 year period just take that
off and you're like whoa that was a game
that I was playing that's crazy and then
he jump into the next virtual world
interesting stuff point number five
multi-dimensional forces at play on
earth keep this one in mind what exists
pass our three-dimensional reality what
is at play here on earth how can we
maximize our potential here on earth how
important is it that we actually do that
together all right I love you guys all
so much I greatly greatly greatly
appreciate you tuning in this has been a
blast top five reasons why we are in a
simulation it's been a lot of fun I'm so
happy that we were able to finally do an
episode on this I hope we can get more
of us around the world playing with this
thought experiment why is it so
important to talk about why we're in a
simulation why is so important to
hypothesize about things like universe
design are about things like the
universe
being code why her do these things
matter so much multidimensionality let's
start talking to each other more about
it let's start asking each other
thought-provoking questions more about
it if you enjoyed your time here leave
us your thoughts in the comments below
let's start a global community
conversation around these topics go and
talk to your friends and your
communities about them let's do it
design universes yourselves and go on
tweak these variables play with them see
what happens and if you guys also had a
good time join us simulation needs to
grow simulation needs to impact more
people simulation needs to do more cool
things and we need more teammates we
have so many cool projects that are all
about awakening and expanding people's
awareness to new dimensions of thinking
of that unity of that collective
learning and consciousness and
intelligence we can do it together join
us below in the links if you want to
join us we love you guys so much we're
super grateful for you tuning in and I'm
Allen sake I'm your host we'll have more
content cool content coming out for you
soon and greatly appreciate you bless
you let's be grateful for this amazing
life that we have together and let's be
vigilant with the way we pass our time
and maximize our own potential and other
people's potentials I love you so much
thank you
and we will talk to you soon